This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法坦诚的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就一定要这么做，听听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
通过 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方，以艰难的方式了解。2023年，“黄金单身汉”克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，对吗？我做假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today I have something a little bit different for you. I'm really excited about this because it is not what we typically do on the show. Most weeks we pick two topics that we encounter in our 20s
相信你的闺蜜。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》（The girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。今天我为你准备了一些稍有不同 A 的内容。我对此感到非常兴奋，因为这并不是我们节目通常的做法。大多数星期，我们会选择两个在我们二十多岁时遇到的主题
and we break down the psychology behind them. Obviously, you guys know this, but this week I want to do the reverse. I want to start with the psychology and the research and the studies and show how that applies to our lives. So, yeah, I thought it would be a little bit fun. In all honesty, I have been experiencing a bit of a creative block recently, and I thought kind of the best way to counteract that is to just get back to the core of why I love this podcast and this job, which is because of the science and how fascinating human behavior and psychology is and how as humans we are really, really, you know, great and really creative at observing this and measuring this and,
并剖析它们背后的心理学。显然，你们都知道这一点，但本周我想反其道而行之。我想从心理学、研究和实验开始，展示这如何应用到我们的生活中。所以，是的，我觉得这会有点有趣。老实说，我最近经历了一些创作瓶颈，我想对抗这种瓶颈的最好方法就是回到我为什么热爱这个播客和这份工作的核心，那就是因为科学以及人类行为和心理学是多么迷人，以及作为人类，我们真的很擅长，你知道的，真的很擅长并且非常有创造力地去观察和衡量这一点，并且
you know, studying ourselves. Also, you know, sometimes there isn't enough space in an episode or a season or it's like kind of never the right time to bring up a study that I love and want to share. So that's what we're going to do today. I'm going to talk about my five favorite psychology papers, psychology studies of all time and what they can tell us about our 20s. Now, these five studies that I have for you today, they are not going to be like your classic psychology studies that people tend to think of. I think we all have some idea of, you know, Pavlov's dogs and the Stanford Prison Experiment and the bystander effect. or the Bobo Doll study, I think that those are part of our, like, regular psychobabble and, like, collective memory.
你知道的，研究我们自己。另外，你知道的，有时一集或一季的时间不够，或者好像从来都不是提出我喜欢并想分享的研究的最佳时机。所以这就是我们今天要做的。我将讨论我心目中历代前五名最喜欢的心理学论文、心理学研究，以及它们能告诉我们关于二十多岁的什么。现在，我今天为大家带来的这五项研究，它们不会像人们通常想的那样，是你经典的心理学研究。我想我们大家对巴甫洛夫的狗、斯坦福监狱实验和旁观者效应都有一些概念。或者波波玩偶实验，我认为这些是我们日常心理学常识和集体记忆的一部分。
But I want to go a little bit deeper, kind of pass the classics into not the everyday, but into the stuff that you would typically say, like published in a journal in this day and age. The studies that don't necessarily make headlines, even if they deserve to. I have a study on jam. I have a study on friendship,
但我想要更深入一点，超越经典，不是那种日常的，而是那种你通常会说，在这个时代在期刊上发表的东西。那些不一定能成为头条新闻的研究，尽管它们当之无愧。我有一项关于果酱的研究。我有一项关于友谊的研究，
one on mental escapism and binge watching television shows. I've got one on gender and imposter syndrome. And as a finale, my favorite study on something totally out of left field, really, which is the ocean and the ancient Greek concept of Thalassotherapy. Okay, reading that through, I'm like, that's quite a mix back. But hopefully there is like something for everybody. There's something for you to learn. I'm so pumped to get into it.
一项关于精神逃避和疯狂追剧的研究。我还有一项关于性别和冒名顶替综合症的研究。作为结尾，我最喜欢的研究是一个完全意料之外的课题，真的，那就是海洋和古希腊的海洋疗法（Thalassotherapy）概念。好吧，读完整段，我觉得这真是个大杂烩。但希望每个人都能从中获得一些东西。有一些东西供你学习。我太兴奋了，迫不及待地要深入探讨了。
it and hopefully just give you some fun new party facts, some fun new psychology trivia. So let's get into it. So I know I promised some lesser known studies, but I'm going to start off with the most well-known one that I kind of have for you. It is known as the Stanford Jam Experiment. If you are a long-time listener of the show, I have talked about this before, but never in its entirety. You would kind of think of all the ways that we can study human psychology that a condiment we put on toast isn't going to be one of them. But I think psychologists and researchers,
希望这能给你提供一些有趣的新派对谈资，一些有趣的新心理学冷知识。那么让我们开始吧。所以我知道我承诺过一些鲜为人知的研究，但我将从我收集的、最广为人知的一项开始。它被称为斯坦福果酱实验。如果你是节目的老听众，我以前谈过这个，但从未完整谈过。你大概会想，在研究人类心理学的所有方法中，吐司上抹的调味品居然不是其中之一。但我认为心理学家和研究人员，
one thing that they do have is like a very creative knack for finding really like different ways to observe decision making and human behavior and consumer choices using things that seem quite ubiquitous. So the Stanford jam experiment, it is a classic study and it was conducted at Stanford University by Sheena Yeager and Mark Lepper in 1995, so 30 years ago. And this study is essentially what created the concept of the paradox of choice. So in this experiment, they wanted to observe shoppers, grocery store shoppers at an upstow supermarket. And how they did that was they presented them with a tasting booth where they could sample different flavors of jam. You know, we've all seen that at like Costco or the grocery store, some new product that they have, you get to have a free sample.
他们拥有一项共同的特质，那就是极具创造力的小聪明，能够利用看似无处不在的事物，找到真正不同的方式来观察决策、人类行为和消费选择。因此，斯坦福果酱实验是一项经典的实验，由谢娜·伊Yee-gar（Sheena Iyengar）和马克·莱珀（Mark Lepper）于1995年在斯坦福大学进行，也就是30年前。这项研究本质上创造了“选择悖论”的概念。在这个实验中，他们希望观察高档超市里的购物者、杂货店购物者。他们是怎么做的呢？他们设立了一个品尝摊位，购物者可以在那里品尝不同口味的果酱。你知道的，我们在好市多（Costco）或杂货店都见过这种情景，他们有一些新产品，你可以获得免费试吃。
And so what they did was they set up two kind of stalls, one on day one and one. Also one on the first weekend. And then the next weekend, they came back. So in the first weekend, which is the first condition, the researchers offered. a display with a limited selection of six different jams, you know, your strawberry, your marmalade, your classics. In the second condition, the weekend after, they offered a much larger selection of 24 jams.
所以他们做的是设置了两个摊位，一个在第一天，一个也是在第一个周末。然后第二个周末，他们回来了。所以，在第一个周末，也就是第一种情况，研究人员提供了一个
What they wanted to see was how likely people were to purchase a jam in each of these conditions. So basically they were observing, investigating how the number of choices we are presented affects our ability to make decisions and to be satisfied with our choices. I think from a surface level, like intuitively, you would think that when people had more jam, they were more likely to make a purchase. They were more likely to buy a jam because there was a greater chance that one of the jars, one of the flavors matched their preferences.
他们想要观察人们在每种情况下购买果酱的可能性有多大。基本上，他们正在观察、调查我们面临的选择数量如何影响我们的决策能力以及对选择的满意度。我认为从表面上看，直觉上，你会认为当人们有更多的果酱可供选择时，他们更有可能购买。他们更有可能买果酱，因为其中一罐、一种口味符合他们偏好的几率更高。
But actually, although people were more attracted to the store when they were a larger number of jams. People asked for more tasters. Fewer people actually made a purchase compared to when there was a smaller assortment of only six jams. The second part of these findings was that those people who had more options on the first weekend were actually a lot less satisfied with their choice and they were more likely to regret it. So when they went and talked to them afterwards and they said, oh, was there another gem that you would have wanted? How happy are you with your choice? How excited are you with your new jam? They'd be like, oh yeah, pretty good. I don't know though. There seems to be like, maybe I should have gotten this other one. What if the strawberry was going to be better than the raspberry?
但实际上，尽管当果酱数量更多时，人们对这家店更感兴趣。人们要求更多的试吃。与只有六种果酱的较小品种相比，实际购买的人更少了。这些发现的第二部分是，在第一个周末有更多选择的那些人，对自己的选择实际上很不满意，他们更有可能感到后悔。所以当事后去跟他们交谈时，他们会说，哦，还有没有你想要的另一种果酱？你对自己的选择有多满意？你对你的新果酱有多兴奋？他们会说，哦，是的，挺好的。不过我不知道。好像，也许我应该买另一个。万一草莓味比树莓味更好呢？
Whereas with the people who had purchased when there were only six gems, they didn't seem to have that same level of back and forth with themselves. So this experiment really highlighted the concept of choice overload, where when we have too many options, this can actually lead to decision paralysis, decrease satisfaction, and even avoidance of making a decision altogether because we have too much to consider. More options might seem like more freedom, but it actually feels quite restrictive because unconsciously I think we feel as if we are more likely to make the wrong choice given we have more options and therefore we don't make one at all. So this has so much application to our 20s, you wouldn't believe it. I think dating apps are the first example I like
而对于那些只有六种果酱可供选择时就购买了的人来说，他们似乎没有对自己进行同样程度的反复拉扯。因此，这个实验真正突显了选择过载的概念，即当我们有太多选择时，这实际上会导致决策瘫痪，满意度下降，甚至完全避免做出决定，因为我们需要考虑的事情太多了。更多的选择可能看起来像更多的自由，但实际上感觉相当具有限制性，因为在潜意识里，我认为我们会觉得鉴于有更多的选项，我们更有可能做出错误的选择，因此我们干脆不做选择。这在我们的二十多岁中有如此多的应用，你简直不敢相信。我认为约会软件是我首先想到的例子
to think of because they are so commonplace in this day and age. Most of us have encountered dating apps in some form. And the thing about them is that they give us so much options and choices. We have like endless matches and our fingertips. If the first person you see on those apps isn't the one, the next person might be. And if they're not, you have another person and another person and another shot after that. But that can actually be really overwhelming because everybody we encounter begins to lose their appeal. The whole process becomes very paralyzing because we have choice overload. We have too many people to consider. We get too paralyzed by the possibility of, wait, was that person the one?
因为它们在当今时代太普遍了。我们大多数人都以某种形式接触过约会软件。关于它们的事情是，它们给了我们如此多的选择和选项。我们的指尖有无数的匹配对象。如果应用上看到的第一个人不是对的人，那么下一个人可能就是。如果他们还不是，你还有另一个人，再另一个人，以及随后的另一次机会。但这实际上可能会让人感到非常不知所措，因为我们遇到的每个人都开始失去吸引力。整个过程变得非常令人瘫痪，因为我们面临选择过载。我们需要考虑的人太多了。我们被这种可能性弄得瘫痪了：等等，那个人是对的人吗？
But what about this person or the next person or the next person? And so we don't end up going on dates or meeting in person or really engaging with any of our candidates because it's hard to choose between them. It's hard to feel satisfied with any one person and want to pursue it further. Another important application is our career choices. I think this is a common experience. There are so many lives. that we want to live, especially in our 20s when like the world feels very open to us.
但这个人呢，还是下一个人，或者下一个人？因此，我们最终没有去约会，没有见面，也没有真正与我们的任何候选人互动，因为很难在他们之间做出选择。很难对任何一个人感到满意并希望进一步追求。另一个重要的应用是我们的职业选择。我认为这是一个常见的经历。有这么多的生活
There are so many future versions of ourselves we want to realize that it can feel, I think, quite impossible to choose just one and feel satisfied for that. Do we go the traditional route? Do we take a gap here? Do we do our masters? Do we want to be more entrepreneurial? Do we want to start our own business? Work for ourselves.
我们想要过，特别是在我们二十多岁的时候，就像世界向我们敞开大门一样。我们想要实现未来版本的自己有那么多，以至于选择其中一个并为此感到满足，我想，会觉得几乎是不可能的。我们是走传统路线吗？我们要gap一年吗？我们要读硕士吗？我们想变得更有创业精神吗？我们想创办自己的公司吗？为自己工作。
work for a company that has security or do something totally out of the ordinary, you know, become an artist or a zookeeper, whatever. I think the example is that our 20s are brimming with opportunity and that is such a blessing, but the more decisions we make when it comes to our careers, the more doors, I think, seem to close. So it makes it quite stressful and confronting. And intuitively, we don't want to make a decision or make a decision. choice and feel like we're limiting ourselves. And that is, you know, a real life example of this
为一家有保障的公司工作，或者做一些完全不同寻常的事情，你知道的，成为一名艺术家或动物园管理员，无论是什么。我认为这个例子说明，我们的二十多岁充满了机遇，这真是一件幸事，但就我们的职业生涯而言，我们做出的决定越多，我想，关闭的门似乎就越多。因此，这让人感到相当压力重重和难以面对。而且凭直觉，我们不想做出决定或做出选择，感觉好像在限制自己。这就是，你知道的，这的一个真实生活例子
jam experiment. So my next study is about another core aspect of our 20s. It's about friendship and how many friends we need to actually feel fulfilled, feel satisfied and to boost our well-being. So in 2015, a 30-year longitudinal study out of the University of Rochester was published in the Journal of Psychology and Ageing. 30 years. That's how long it had taken. And it determined that in our 20s, it is actually the quantity of friends that we have. Whilst in our 30s, it's the quality that seems to matter when it comes to our psychological well-being. Essentially, what this study kind of suggested or concluded is that in our 20s, we should actually be focused on building a large, expansive network, even if not everybody, is hand-selected and our best friend, whereas in our 30s, it's about pruning those relationships, being comfortable
果酱实验。所以我的下一项研究是关于我们二十多岁的另一个核心方面。它是关于友谊的，我们需要多少个朋友才能真正感到充实、感到满意并提升我们的幸福感。因此，在2015年，罗切斯特大学（University of Rochester）一项为期30年的纵向研究发表在《心理学与老化》杂志上。30年。这就是花费的时间。它确定，在我们二十多岁时，实际上是朋友的数量。而在我们三十多岁时，在我们的心理健康方面，似乎更重要的是质量。本质上，这项研究所暗示或得出的结论是，在我们二十多岁时，我们实际上应该专注于建立一个庞大、广阔的网络，即使不是每个人都是精挑细选的最要好的朋友，而在我们三十多岁时，则是关于精简这些关系，习惯于
with some of them fading, and really seeking out quality friendship over quantity. So, how did they conclude this? This research, like I said, published in 2015, so only 10 years ago, but it began in the 1970s. So the researcher, Paul Dubastain, he is a psychiatry professor at the University of Rochester, and he followed 100 students who were once students at the university, so they were one students, not anymore. He followed 100 X students alumni from when they were students through their 20s, their 30s, and their 40s. Now, at multiple points in their 20s and 30s, they were asked to record their daily interactions with others and to score them on intimacy and unpleasantness. So they weren't doing this like all the time.
其中一些关系的淡去，并真正寻求质的友谊胜过量。那么，他们是如何得出这个结论的？这项研究，就像我说的，发表于2015年，所以仅仅是10年前，但它始于20世纪70年代。因此，研究员保罗·杜巴斯坦（Paul Duberstein），他是罗切斯特大学的精神病学教授，他追踪了100名曾经是该大学学生的学生，所以他们曾经是学生，现在不是了。他追踪了100名前学生校友，从他们还是学生时一直到他们二十多岁、三十多岁和四十多岁。现在，在他们二十多岁和三十多岁的多个时间点，他们被要求记录他们与他人的日常互动，并根据亲密程度和不愉快程度对其进行评分。所以他们并不是一直在这样做。
He would kind of like pop back up to them for just a small period and say, hey, I just need you to take some notes on this for a couple days or for a week. Decades later, he got back in touch with them and he asked them some questions relating to. their psychological well-being, their sense of loneliness, and quality of friendship. And what they found was that having too many friends at 30 was actually a bit of a problem because it could prevent you from developing meaningful relationships. But on the flip side, just meeting more people in your 20s, regardless of the depth of your interactions and your relationships, that kind of has its own merits.
他会像这样短暂地回到他们身边，说，嘿，我只需要你做几天或一周的笔记。几十年后，他又联系了他们，问了他们一些与
So what does this study tell us about friendship in our 20s? I think it tells us two things. The first thing is that you don't need to be too worried about meeting your best friend at this age if you're in your 20s. You don't need to be concerned by the fact that you haven't found your people yet because you have time and it seems that this decade is about prioritizing just getting out there, right? Just having those situational friendships, those fleeting moments, even if they don't last, our 30s are the decade for quality friendship and for kind of
那么这项研究告诉我们关于二十多岁时友谊的什么？我认为它告诉我们两件事。第一件事是，如果你正处于二十多岁，你不需要太担心在这个年龄遇到你最好的朋友。你不需要为自己还没找到志同道合的人而烦恼，因为你还有时间，而且这个十年似乎就是要把走出去放在首位，对吧？只要拥有那些情境友谊，那些稍纵即逝的时刻，即使它们不会持久，我们的三十多岁才是优质友谊的十年，是为了
fine-tuning and deepening those pre-existing relationships. I will say that a small problem with this research was that it was mainly conducted before the invention of social media. Things have changed a lot now. So it would be really fascinating to see how these results may shift as we have more interactions online and you know face-to-face interactions aren't always the norm for catching up and communicating and chatting with our friends i think one way you could adapt this study is to kind of like download software onto participants phones that monitors who they talk to on social media whether
微调和深化那些预先存在的关系。我得说，这项研究的一个小问题是它主要是在社交媒体发明之前进行的。现在事情已经发生了很大变化。因此，随着我们在网上有更多的互动，而且面对面互动并不总是与朋友叙旧、交流和聊天的常态，这些结果将如何变化，这将是非常迷人的，我认为你可以调整这项研究的一种方法是，在参与者的手机上下载软件，监控他们在社交媒体上与谁交谈。
they speak to the same five people or like a broad community and then see how that relates to well-being in our 20s or 30s or whether it's the quantity of interest. interactions like dictated by social media versus the quality, which we would just kind of assume come from in-person interactions that count. I don't know. Just an interesting way of like adapting this to a modern context because I think it could really tell us a lot more if you want to read about the study, any of the studies, I really would recommend the article in the description.
无论是与相同的五个人交谈还是与广泛的社区交谈，然后看看这与我们二十多岁或三十多时的幸福感有何关联，或者是由社交媒体决定的互动的数量，与我们通常认为来自面对面互动的重要质量相比如何。我不知道。这只是将此适应现代背景的一种有趣方式，因为我认为如果你想阅读关于这项研究的内容，任何研究，我真的会推荐描述中的文章。
So our third study is entirely different. We are switching gears away from our careers and friendship and relationship. to our TVs, to our laptops. We're going to talk about binge watching. Mental escapism, loneliness, how those three things are correlated or have a relationship to each other. I was having this conversation with my friends the other day
所以我们的第三项研究完全不同。我们将转换方向，从我们的职业、友谊和关系转向我们的电视、我们的笔记本电脑。我们将讨论疯狂追剧。精神逃避、孤独感，这三者是如何相关的或彼此之间存在什么联系。我前几天和我的朋友们在谈论这个话题
that the way TV shows are released these days makes them so much easier to binge watch and consume rapidly. I don't know, if you're in your 20s, like in your mid-late 20s, you will remember when like gossip girl and glee would come out and you would have to like wait each week for the next episode and then they would like take a two week break like randomly over Christmas or in the summertime and you would have to watch like Simpsons reruns or whatever it was
现在电视节目的发行方式使得它们更容易被疯狂观看和快速消费。我不知道，如果你二十多岁，比如二十多岁的中后期，你会记得《绯闻女孩》（Gossip Girl）和《欢乐合唱团》（Glee）是如何上映的，你必须每周等待下一集，然后他们会在圣诞节期间或夏季随机休息两周，你必须观看《辛普森一家》（Simpsons）的重播或其他任何内容
nowadays like the whole thing comes out all at once and companies like Netflix and Hulu and Apple Amazon Prime they're really focused on like these mini series that we can consume really quickly and then immediately go looking for something else. I'm going to admit I'm into it. I just finished baby reindeer on Netflix. I'm like captivated. I got through it in three days. And it's kind of one of those behaviors that you just fall into.
如今，整个剧集一次性全部放出，像Netflix、Hulu、Apple和Amazon Prime这样的公司，他们真正专注于我们可以非常快速消费的迷你剧，然后立即寻找其他东西。我承认我很喜欢。我刚刚在Netflix上看完《驯鹿宝贝》（Baby Reindeer）。我着迷了。我在三天内看完了。而且这可以说是那种你会不由自主陷入的行为。
I think that it's a lot more common though amongst people who are seeking a kind of mental escapism from their daily lives. Whether that's because their jobs aren't going well, they're lonely, something else is going on, their relationship is breaking down, we turn to binge watching as a form of mental escapism. So the study I want to talk about that discovered this correlation was published in 2021, and it's titled Loneliness, Escapism and Identification with Media Characters, an Exploration of the Psychological Factors underlying binge watching tendency. Okay, a bit of a mouthful. So in this study, they had a sample of 490 individuals.
不过，我认为这在那些寻求从日常生活中获得某种精神逃避的人当中更为常见。无论是他们的工作不顺利、感到孤独、发生了其他事情、他们的关系正在破裂，我们都会转向疯狂追剧作为一种精神逃避的形式。因此，我想要讨论的发现这种相关性的研究发表于2021年，题为《孤独感、逃避现实与对媒体角色的认同：疯狂追剧倾向背后的心理因素探索》。好吧，名字有点长。在这项研究中，他们有490个个体的样本。
mainly from the UK and the United States. And they were asked about their typical media usage and how many hours they spent watching TV along with which streaming services they were using. That could include any of them, you know, like we said, Amazon, Netflix, Stan, they just wanted to know. They were then measured for loneliness using the UCLA loneliness scale
主要来自英国和美国。他们被问及他们典型的媒体使用情况以及他们花多少小时看电视，以及他们正在使用哪些流媒体服务。这可以包括其中的任何一个，你知道的，正如我们所说，亚马逊、Netflix、Stan，他们只是想知道。然后使用UCLA孤独量表对他们的孤独感进行测量
and a binge watching tendency test, which is a real thing we can measure how likely you are to binge watch a TV show. It asks questions like, I always need to watch more episodes to feel satisfied. Do you strongly agree or strongly disagree? I keep watching even when I have other things I need to do. I avoid sleep to keep watching my TV series.
以及疯狂追剧倾向测试，这是一种我们可以衡量你疯狂追剧可能性的真实测试。它会问这样的问题：我总是需要看更多集才能感到满足。你非常同意还是非常不同意？即使我还有其他事情要做，我也一直在看。我为了继续看我的电视剧而避免睡觉。
Those are kind of the questions that operationalize this concept of binge watching. So when the researchers looked at the results, what they found was that higher feelings of loneliness are associated with higher levels of problematic binge watching behaviors and excessive TV consumption. This was interpreted as a form of mental escapism, wanting a mental break from your daily life by seeking solace in something that is entirely different. And the reason why this kind of behavior would be so common amongst those who are looking for a mental escape is because binge watching is so low effort and undemanding,
这些就是将疯狂追剧这个概念具体化的问题。因此，当研究人员查看结果时，他们发现更高的孤独感与更高水平的问题性疯狂追剧行为和过度电视消费有关。这被解释为一种精神逃避的形式，希望通过在完全不同的事物中寻求慰藉来获得对日常生活精神上的喘息。这种行为在那些寻求精神逃避的人当中如此普遍的原因是，疯狂追剧所需努力极少且不费脑筋，
but it provides a really engaging distraction even when our mental energy reserves are super depleted and we're super drained. I actually think that binge watching is an activity that it's easier to continue than to quit, right? Like when you're approaching the end of an episode, the next one is immediately going to play, meaning that it's more demanding for you to stop and turn the TV off than it is to just continue the show. I also think that when we continually watch the same kind of TV series that features the same characters,
但即使我们的心理能量储备极度枯竭、筋疲力尽时，它也能提供一种非常引人入胜的分心方式。我实际上认为疯狂追剧是一种比停止更容易继续下去的活动，对吧？就像当你接近一集尾声时，下一集会立即播放，这意味着停止并关掉电视比继续看剧需要你付出更多的精力。我还认为，当我们连续观看包含相同角色的同类电视剧时，
the same plots, the same locations, it's less cognitively demanding than switching to other activities, which is why when we're going through, I think, tough, lonely, draining periods of burnout, whatever it is, we are more likely to turn to, you know, television. or miniseries or Netflix for comfort. Media companies leverage this. They know we have a lot going on and they know that if they provide a comfortable place for our brains to relax,
相同的剧情、相同的地点，比起转向其他活动，它所需的认知需求更少，这就是为什么当我们经历艰难、孤独、消耗精力的倦怠期或其他什么时期时，我们更有可能转向，你知道的，电视。或者迷你剧或Netflix寻求安慰。媒体公司利用这一点。他们知道我们有很多事情要忙，他们知道如果他们为我们的大脑提供一个放松的舒适地方，
we'll keep coming back, even if it's at the expense of other things we want to do with our days, with our lives. What can we kind of take from this? Well, I think it's about being aware of the why. Why can't we stop? Why do we have to watch the whole thing in one night? Why does so many of us find it easier to kind of switch off in this way and stay that way for hours than to do something more active in our lives?
我们会不断回来，即使这是以牺牲我们想用一天的时间、我们的生活去做其他事情为代价的。我们能从中得到什么呢？嗯，我认为这在于意识到“为什么”。为什么我们停不下来？为什么我们必须在一晚上看完整部剧？为什么我们中的许多人发现以这种方式关机并保持几个小时比在生活中做一些更积极的事情更容易？
I don't think that it's always necessarily a bad thing, but when it does become a form of mental escapism, whereby it's like you're kind of sitting into a whole new reality, you're completely switching off from your life, you're trying not to engage with what's actually going on in your every day. that can be quite problematic. I really love this study so much because I think it makes a lot of sense, right? We find so much comfort in TV shows in the media, in binge watching something repetitive or something that we know or something that has just come out and it's exciting and novel.
我不认为这绝对是一件坏事，但当它成为一种精神逃避的形式时，就像你好像坐进了全新的现实中，你完全脱离了你的生活，你试图不去参与你日常生活中实际发生的事情，这可能会相当有问题。我真的很喜欢这项研究，因为它非常合乎情理，对吧？我们在电视节目、媒体、疯狂观看重复的东西、我们熟悉的东西或是刚刚上映且令人兴奋和新颖的东西中找到了极大的慰藉。
But sometimes we don't really think about the why behind our excessive consumption behaviours. So it's a fascinating one. Again, it will be in the description. So far, we've covered my top three. We have two left. And we're going to get to them after this short break. So stay with us.
但有时我们并没有真正思考我们过度消费行为背后的原因。所以这是一个迷人的研究。同样，它会在描述中。到目前为止，我们已经介绍了前三项。我们还剩下两个。在短暂的休息后，我们将讨论它们。所以请继续收听。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中。我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养恢复力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过它的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。澄清一下，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为crack。我随时准备谈论crack，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论crack的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线贯穿其中。我们现在还有艾滋病（AIDS）摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难的教训》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太投入于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候做得够多了。因为人们盯着记分牌看。生活变成了一场胜负游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得做一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
当你在世时？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难的教训》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《艰难的教训》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在这个特定的测试中作假了两次，对吧？我做假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detainty. to crack the case.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用来做什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着剧集的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·奥布莱恩。欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。我想我们都听说过冒名顶替综合症的概念。冒名顶替综合症是指一种心理模式，在这种模式下，个人，比如你和我，怀疑自己的成就。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura O'Brien. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we've all heard about the idea of imposter syndrome. Imposter syndrome refers to a psychological pattern where individuals, like you and I, doubt our accomplishments.
我们有一种挥之不去的恐惧，即被揭露为骗子、说谎者，尽管有证据表明我们有能力、成功，而且我们是聪明人。我们觉得自己很不配。我们觉得我们的成功和成就完全归因于运气或外部因素，而不是我们自己的能力，因此我们经常处于一种恐惧状态中，担心人们会发现我们真的不知道自己在做什么。这是一种非常普遍的感觉，也是一个众所周知的术语，以至于我们其实并不知道它来自哪里。这就把我带到了第四项研究：高成就女性中的冒名顶替现象：动力学与治疗干预。这就是这篇研究文章的标题，该文章于20世纪70年代的1978年在佐治亚州立大学再次进行。
And we have a persistent fear of being exposed. as a fraud, as a liar, despite the evidence of our competence and of our success in the fact that we are intelligent people. We feel really undeserving. We feel like our successes and achievements all come down to luck or external factors rather than our own abilities and therefore we're constantly in a state of fear that people are going to figure out that we really don't know what we're doing. This is such a common feeling and it's also such a well-known term that I don't think we actually know where it comes from. So this brings me to study number four, the imposter phenomenon in high achieving women, dynamics and therapeutic intervention. That is the title of this article of this study that was conducted at Georgia State University once again back in the 70s in 1978.
因此，这项研究和分析重点关注了150名非常成功的女性，这些女性获得了博士学位，是受人尊敬的医生、教授，因学术成就而受到认可。她们处于各自领域的顶尖地位。将她们联系在一起的不仅仅是她们的成就，还有那种麻木的、觉得自己配不上这一切的感觉，尽管有所有相反的证据。例如，在这项研究中，这两位研究人员，保琳·克兰斯博士（Dr. Pauline Clance）、苏珊·伊米斯博士（Dr. Susan Imes），她们与这些女性交谈，这150名女性。他们在研究期间收集的一些陈述和自我报告包括，这些学生绝对确信，在她们被录取进入一所声誉卓著的大学时，存在某种行政错误。有大量的研究生考试成绩非常高，他们会满怀诚意地对他们说，她们内心深处相信一定是发生了什么事情。她们的分数错了。她们的论文被错误评分了。
So this research and analysis, it focused on 150 highly successful women, women who had earned PhDs, who were respected doctors, professors, recognized for the academic success. They were at the top of their field. And they were all linked not just by their achievements, but this paralyzing sense that they didn't deserve any of it, despite all the evidence to the contrary. So for example, in this study, these two researchers, Dr. Pauline Clance, Dr. Susan Immis, they spoke to these women, these 150 women. And some of the statements and self-reports that they collected during the study included these students who were like absolutely convinced that there had been some like administrative error in admitting them to like a really prestigious college. There were heaps of graduate students who had really high exam scores and they would say to them full honestly, like they believe this to their core that something must have happened. Their scores were wrong. Their papers had been misgraded.
教授们的判断有误。还有教授和医生会说，我的甄选过程中出了某种错误，才让我获得了终身教职。或者很明显，我能处在这个位置是因为我的能力被高估了。还有另一位女性拥有两个硕士学位、一个博士学位、众多出版物，是一名讲师，她基本上说，我没有资格教学。这是一个错误。这只是运气。
There was faulty judgment by the professors. There were also professors and doctors who would say some mistake was made in my selection process that gave me my tenure. or obviously I'm in this position because my abilities have been overestimated. There was another woman with two master's degrees, a PhD, numerous publications, who was a lecturer, and she basically said, I'm unqualified to teach. This was a mistake. This is just luck.
显然有人搞砸了，当他们发现时，我会有大麻烦。这在这些研究人员看来是如此不合理和怪异，因为似乎所有的证据都在那里，这些女性应该对她们的成就在她们的生活中处于什么位置感到完全踏实，但在20世纪70年代的背景下，她们假设女性比男性经历这种“综合症”更多，是因为她们当时被社会化要求要谦虚、要温顺、不要显得聪明、不要为自己的成功邀功，而男性则被允许成为英雄。他们被允许自信，如果不是傲慢的话，并公开庆祝他们的成功和成就。
Somebody is obviously screwed up and when they find out I'm in big trouble. this seemed so irrational and bizarre to these researchers because it just seemed that all of the evidence was there these women should be totally secure in their accomplishments and where they were in their lives but within the context of the 1970s they kind of hypothesized that the reason women were experiencing this like syndrome more than men was because of how they were socialized at the time to be humble, to be meek, to not be intelligent, to not take credit for their successes, whereas men were allowed to be the heroes. They were allowed to be confident, if not arrogant, and celebrate themselves publicly for their
她们还推测，由于当时女性在这些高调、卓越的学术和专业环境中并不常见，她们对自己的成功其实没有叙事框架，因为与周围的人相比，这显得太出乎意料了。因此，最自然的结论是，这一定是个侥幸。他们寻找解释的另一个方面是家庭动力和这些女性的童年。这是冒名顶替综合症的一个组成部分，我认为人们通常不知道冒名顶替综合症是如何真正扎根于我们的婴儿期、我们的童年、我们的
successes and their achievements. They also kind of speculated that because at the time women weren't super common in these high-profile exceptional academic and professional environments, they didn't really have a narrative for their success because it seemed so unexpeachment. expected compared to those around them. So the most natural conclusion was that it must be a fluke. The other thing they also sought an explanation in was family dynamics and the childhood that these women had. And this is a component of imposter syndrome I think people don't typically know about how imposter syndrome really does have its roots in our infancy, in our childhood, in our
她们的成功与成就。他们还推测，由于当时女性在这些备受瞩目的杰出学术和专业环境中并不常见，她们实际上并没有关于自身成功的叙事，因为与周围的人相比，这种成功显得极其意外。因此，最自然的结论就是这纯属侥幸。他们寻找解释的另一个方向是这些女性的家庭动力学和童年经历。我认为这是冒名顶替综合征的一个鲜为人知的组成部分，即冒名顶替综合征确实植根于我们的婴儿期、童年期以及
adolescence. What they concluded was that these quote unquote impostors, they typically fell into one of two groups. They fell into a group of high achievers or the designated kind of intelligent member of the family or they were the sensitive member of the family, not particularly special, not really made to shine. So the intelligent child constantly worked to meet their family prophecy that they were brilliant. She was told numerous examples of how she would always been bright, how she was such a quick learner, how she excelled from an early age. In the family members' eyes, I think she's perfect. They lavish her with praise. But then she encounters things the older she gets that she can't do. And so she begins to doubt her abilities. She no longer
青春期。他们的结论是，这些所谓的“冒牌货”通常分为两类。他们要么属于高成就者群体，要么是家里指定的所谓聪明成员，或者他们是家里敏感的成员，并不是特别特别，也没有真正能闪光的机会。因此，聪明的孩子不断努力去实现他们家庭关于他们才华横溢的预言。她被告知了无数关于她一直以来如何聪明、如何学得如此之快、如何从小就表现优异的例子。在家庭成员眼里，我认为她是完美的。他们对她赞不绝口。但随着年龄的增长，她遇到了自己做不到的事情。于是她开始怀疑自己的能力。她不再
lives up to this like perfection with ease idea that her parents and her family have pushed on her. And if she's not the genius that she was always told she was, she's an intellectual imposter. That was group one of these women who were experiencing imposter syndrome. There were the women who, since young age, you know, were lucky enough to have parents and family who really celebrated them, perhaps too much so to the point where they kind of had a too big to fail mentality. On the other hand, they have this other group of women who were experiencing imposter syndrome who were kind of always second, who were always runner up compared to the bright sibling. They could never really impress their parents. Their achievements and performance and
符合父母和家人强加给她的这种“毫不费力的完美”的想法。如果她不是一直被告知的那个天才，她就是一个知识上的冒牌货。这是经历过冒牌者综合症的女人的第一组。还有另一组女性，从小就很幸运地拥有真正赞美她们的父母和家庭，也许赞美得有点过头了，以至于她们产生了一种“大到不能倒”的心态。另一方面，这群女性经历冒牌者综合症是因为她们总是名列第二，和聪明的兄弟姐妹相比总是亚军。她们从来无法真正给父母留下深刻印象。她们的成就、表现和
accolades were never really seen as that special. To like directly quote from the article, these women in one domain really crave validation and keep pushing to prove their intellectual competence kind of in rebellion of what their parents and their family has always said. But on the other hand, they also think that their family must be correct. So this woman secretly doubts her intellect and begins to wonder whether she has actually gained high marks because of her social skills, because she has tricked people, because there's been a mistake. And so the imposter syndrome emerges from a constantly wanting to prove that she is intelligent, that she is worthy, that she is successful, but then having that self-doubt that comes from that inner voice
荣誉从来没有被真正看作是那么特别。直接引用文章中的话说：“这些女性在一个领域里非常渴望获得认可，并不断努力证明她们的智力能力，这在某种程度上是对父母和家庭一直以来所说的话的一种反叛。”但另一方面，她们也认为她们的家人一定是正确的。于是这个女人暗自怀疑自己的智力，开始琢磨自己之所以能拿高分，是不是因为社交技巧，是不是因为骗了别人，是不是弄错了。因此，冒牌者综合症源于不断想要证明自己很聪明、自己很有价值、自己很成功，但随之而来的却是那种源于内心声音的自我怀疑
her parents have instilled in her, that she isn't smart enough, that she doesn't deserve this. I really love this study because it was honestly one of the first ever academic pieces of research that focused on successful women and their psychology and their upbringing. And it was conducted, again, by two really amazing female doctors and female psychologists who went on to create that term through this research, that term imposter syndrome, that is now like a huge part of our collective psychobabble and our language. But when you really look into it further and you actually read their analysis and their suggestions, there are so many more fascinating conclusions than most of us are aware of.
父母灌输给她的，觉得她不够聪明，觉得她不配拥有这一切。我真的很喜欢这项研究，因为老实说，它是历史上第一批真正关注成功女性及其心理和成长经历的学术研究之一。而且，它再次由两位非常了不起的女性医生和女性心理学家进行，她们通过这项研究创造了这个词——冒牌者综合症，现在这个词已经成为我们集体心理闲聊和语言中不可或缺的一部分。但如果你深入研究并真正阅读她们的分析和建议，你会发现其中有着比我们大多数人所知晓的更多迷人结论。
And I think we like to throw around the term imposter syndrome, but there is a lot of depth behind that, a lot of fascinating history, and of course psychology that this study really goes into. So honestly, it is worth reading. The first time I came across it, it genuinely changed so much about how I saw how I saw myself, how I saw my friends, my family, my childhood, my present day insecurities and self-doubts. Again, it will be in the description.
我想我们喜欢随口抛出“冒牌者综合症”这个词，但它的背后其实有很多深度、很多迷人的历史，当然还有这项研究所深入探讨的心理学。所以老实说，非常值得一读。我第一次接触到它时，它确实彻底改变了我看待自己、看待朋友、家人、童年、当下的不安全感和自我怀疑的方式。同样，它会放在简介里。
So this brings us to our fifth and final study of the day. And I want to end on something kind of positive and beautiful and joyful. So we're going to talk about a study that really articulates some of the beauty and nice parts about being human. and kind of the fact that we are really connected to nature and all living things around us. So the whole sub-discipline of eco-psychology is really focused on that. And if you've listened to this episode that we did previously on the healing power of nature, you'll know I kind of have a real soft spot for any research, any concepts, any theories
这就把我们带到了今天的第五个也是最后一个研究。我想以某种积极、美好、快乐的事情来结束。所以我们要讨论一项真正阐述了作为人类的一些美好和可爱之处的研究，以及我们与自然和周围所有生命真正紧密相连的事实。生态心理学整个子学科都真正专注于这一点。如果你听过我们之前做过的那期关于自然治愈力量的节目，你就会知道我对任何研究、任何概念、任何理论都有着一种真正的软肋
that emphasizes our relationship and the importance of being outdoors and rewilding our minds and our bodies. I also grew up really close to the ocean. It was such like a significant part of my childhood, like going down to burly heads and Corrumban waters in the Gold Coast and the sea is like one of those places that I feel very comfortable in and at peace. And I think it's, you know, tangent here, but it's a really huge blessing to have grown up in a country that has such a huge beach culture and like access to this natural asset. And the thing that I've always found is that being by the ocean,
强调我们的关系以及在户外活动、重塑我们的心灵和身体的重要性。我在海边长大。这是我童年非常重要的一部分，比如去黄金海岸的伯利角和库伦班水域，大海是我感到非常舒适和内心平静的地方之一。我觉得，顺便说一句，在一个拥有如此庞大的海滩文化和获取这种自然资源的国家长久居住，真是一件天大的福气。我一直发现的一件事是，在海边，
is one of the easiest ways to reduce my stress levels, to reset, to bring about perspective in my life. My dad used to always say that the ocean is nature's natural healer and it eases all wounds, physical and mental. And this study I'm about to tell you about actually seems to provide some science and some evidence for that. So this study was conducted in Japan and is titled The Effects of Coastal Environmental. on well-being. So they wanted to know whether living by the ocean was better for your health and better, especially for your emotional and psychological health. And they did this by comparing 518 residents from the Hyogo Prefecture, which is where Kobe is, the origin of Kobe Beath.
是减轻压力水平、重置生活、为生活带来视角最简单的方法之一。我爸爸过去常说，大海是自然界的天然治疗师，它能抚平所有身体和心理上的伤口。我接下来要告诉你们的这项研究似乎确实为这一点提供了一些科学依据和证据。这项研究在日本进行，题为《海岸环境对幸福感的影响》。所以他们想知道住在海边是否对你的健康更好，尤其是对你的情绪和心理健康更好。他们通过比较来自兵库县（也就是神户的发源地，神户牛肉的发源地）的518名居民来做到这一点。
And they compared people in this area who lived by the sea and people who lived inland and in the major cities. And what they found was this. People by the seaside seemed a whole, lot happier. They reported higher positive psychological effects of the ocean. This was particularly the case for women and elderly residents, but actually in general, there was not a single person who wasn't happier living by the sea. And they wanted to know why this was. Well, I think the argument they made is that the coast is a therapeutic landscape. It brought upon really important and strong feelings of restoration of awe and a peace of mind which it seemed harder for people who lived in big cities to achieve and that all kind of contributed to a greater sense of mental well-being.
他们比较了这一地区居住在海边的人和居住在内陆及大城市的人。他们的发现是这样的：海边的人似乎要快乐得多。他们报告说，大海具有更高的积极心理影响。对于女性和老年居民来说尤其如此，但实际上总的来说，没有一个人在海边生活得不开心。他们想知道为什么会这样。嗯，我认为他们的论点是，海岸是一个治疗性的景观。它带来了非常重要且强烈的恢复感、敬畏感和平静感，而居住在大城市的人似乎很难做到这一点，这一切都在一定程度上促成了更高的心理幸福感。
Access to the ocean, to the sea, to the coast it also seemed to play part in this sense of like magnitude and the sense that we are small but because of that what we're doing doesn't matter, if that makes sense. So it feels quite existential, but actually it was quite liberating. There's also, to follow that up, another paper that looked into this original study, and it found that there is a more neurological impact of the ocean in our psychology. Staring at the sea, staring at the waves, literally changes our brain wave frequency. It kind of puts us in a mild, meditative state that has a relaxing effect on all of our senses when we allow ourselves to kind of watch the ebb and flow of the swell that has a genuine impact on our brainwave frequency
接触海洋、大海、海岸，似乎也在这种宏大感以及“我们很渺小，但正因如此，我们正在做的事其实并不重要”的感觉中发挥了作用，如果这说得通的话。所以这感觉相当存在主义，但实际上却非常解放。顺便说一句，还有另一篇论文探讨了这项最初的研究，它发现海洋对我们的心理有着更神经系统层面的影响。盯着大海看，盯着海浪看，会彻底改变我们的脑电波频率。它把我们带入一种轻度的冥想状态，当我们允许自己去观察海浪的起伏时，这对我们所有的感官都有放松的效果，这确实对我们的脑电波频率产生了真正的影响
on our brain activity. This may be a recent study, but it's not a recent concept. There is a Greek idea known as Thalassar therapy, which stems from the Greek word Thalasa meaning C and therapy. basically the ancient Greek believed that the ocean had genuine healing properties and i kind of have to agree it encompassed like this whole range of treatments like philassotherapy was like a genuine kind of like treatment plan you could get from your ancient greek doctor and it included things like um seawater baths marine mud wraps seaweed wraps inhalation of seamis and these treatments were were believed to have various benefits, not just physical. They thought they helped with circulation, with relieving muscle tension, with kind of
对我们的大脑活动。这可能是一项最新的研究，但这并不是一个新鲜的概念。有一个希腊概念被称为“海洋疗法”（Thalassotherapy），它源于希腊语“Thalassa”（意为海洋）和“therapy”（疗法）。基本上，古希腊人认为海洋具有真正的治疗特性，我也有点赞同。它涵盖了一系列治疗方法，海洋疗法就像是你从古希腊医生那里得到的真正的一种治疗计划，它包括诸如海水浴、海洋泥敷剂、海藻敷剂、吸入海雾等，人们相信这些治疗方法不仅在身体上有各种好处。他们认为它们有助于血液循环，缓解肌肉紧张，以及某种程度上
detoxifying the body. But on the psychological and mental level, it also helped promote relaxation. And it brought about a level of mental clarity and peace for these individuals that is so valuable even to this day for our emotional state. I got to say, I love this study so much because it really highlights how important nature is for our health, which is something that I think we tend to neglect as cities become more concrete, more industrialized, our life becomes busier, and we are naturally kind of separated from the natural environments that we evolved in. I think it's also a good reminder that if you're feeling a bit
排毒身体。但在心理和精神层面，它也有助于促进放松。它为这些个体带来了一种精神上的清晰和平静，即使在今天，对于我们的情绪状态来说，这也是极其宝贵的。我得说，我非常喜欢这项研究，因为它真正突出了自然对我们健康的重要性，随着城市变得越来越混凝土化、越来越工业化，我们的生活变得越来越忙碌，而我们自然而然地与我们进化而来的自然环境隔离开来，我认为我们往往会忽视这一点。我想这也是一个很好的提醒，如果你觉得有点
restless, a bit unsettled, a bit unsure about your future, about your current state of affairs, if you're kind of looking for meaning, you're looking for peace, the ocean is a really good. good place to go. It is such a restorative environment. I always say you never regret a swim in the ocean. And I think that's true. I think it's true because when you are like very much immersed in this natural environment, you feel very small but that allows you to feel very free. And it allows you to really slow down from a lot of the industrial, you know, hustle culture, rise and grind mentality and like focus in on the fact that you are human, the fact that everything's going to be okay, the fact that, you know, you have this place for rest and this place for peace where nature doesn't
焦躁不安，有点飘忽不定，对未来、对现状有点不确定，如果你在寻找意义，在寻找平静，大海是一个非常好的去处。这是一个如此具有恢复力的环境。我总是说，去海里游泳你永远不会后悔。我认为这是真的。我认为这是真的，因为当你真正沉浸在这个自然环境中时，你会觉得自己非常渺小，但这能让你感到非常自由。它能让你从许多工业化的“内卷文化”、“起早贪黑”的心态中慢下来，专注于这样一个事实：你是一个人，一切都会好起来的，你有这样一个休息和获得平静的地方，在这里自然并
care about you and isn't that kind of like a beautiful, beautiful thing? So that was the final study that I had for you today. I really hope that you enjoyed this. This was actually so fun for me. I think it's so rare that I get to really break into like specific articles and studies and spend like some serious time on them, let alone getting to do that for five of my favorites. So I really hope that you learned something. I hope that you picked up maybe a new word, a new piece of psychology trivia, a new thing to bring up at work, bring up to your friends, bring up to your family. And as always, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to share it with a friend
不在乎你，难道这不是一件非常美好的事情吗？这就是我主要为你们准备的最后一份研究。我真的希望你们会喜欢。这对我来说其实非常有趣。我觉得我很少有机会真正深入研究特定的文章和花大量时间在上面，更不用说为我最喜欢的五个都这么做了。所以我真的希望你们学到了一些东西。我希望你们可能学到了一个新词、一点新的心理学冷知识，或者是一个可以在工作、朋友和家人面前提起的新话题。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时与朋友分享
or give us five stars on Apple or Spotify or wherever you're listening. it really does help the show grow. And if you enjoy this content, it would be great if it reached new audiences and new people. So make sure you are following along. Make sure you're subscribed. If you have something to contribute based on this discussion, if you have a favorite psychology study that you want me to talk about, if you have anything to say about the ones I've already spoken about,
或者在苹果播客、Spotify或你收听的任何地方给我们打五星好评。这确实有助于节目的成长。如果你喜欢这些内容，如果它能接触到新的受众和新的人，那就太棒了。所以请确保你正在关注。请确保你已订阅。如果你对这次讨论有什么想贡献的，如果你有什么希望我谈论的最喜欢的心理学研究，如果你对我已经谈过的内容有什么想说的，
please feel free to reach out to me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Also with episode suggestions, I love hearing from you guys. I love getting your feedback. So make sure you're following us there as well. And as always, be kind, be gentle to yourselves. And we'll talk very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
请随时在Instagram上联系我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。也欢迎提供节目建议，我喜欢听你们大家的意见。我喜欢收集你们的反馈。所以也请务必在那里关注我们。一如既往，对人好一点，对你们自己温柔一点。我们很快就会聊。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere. But you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话。但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吧？我动过一次测试的手脚。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，莱斯利，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困的爱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健康和建立韧性的标志。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
这就是《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时。她们开始将命运掌握在自己手中。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听女友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。